[Music]
so yeah welcome everybody we're gonna
talk about time and give you an
introduction to timely data flow and as
Timo mentioned my name is Malta this is
Nicholas we are working in a software
consultancy which we co-founded - called
clockworks and we're also using the
timely data flow ecosystem there to
drive our business and help companies
with their data journeys and the timely
ecosystem was originally invented by
Frank McSherry and we also did research
at ETH Zurich and I'm still researching
at ETH Zurich systems group in to timely
data flow under the supervision of
Bosnia Halawa so if we look at stream
processing generally what we think would
be cool to reach as a trifecta of
timeliness consistency and expressivity
so what do we mean by that by timeliness
we mean on the one hand we want to do
very low latency computations and and on
the other hand this also means the time
that it takes some new data that flows
into our system until an end user
actually sees updated results secondly
we also want to make sure these consider
this results are actually correct so of
course we're interested in consistency
and in a streaming system we often face
issues such as late arrivals and so we
have to handle this in some way lastly
we are interested in expressive
computations for example if you take a
traditional relational database you have
even support for recursive queries and
very complex computations and we would
like to translate this into a streaming
setting as well if we are just focusing
on timeliness we could just use mave
status processing so we just stream in
some data compute some something on it
and stream it out right as we compute
something of course this gives us great
latency characteristics but we face the
issue of late arrivals and we also can
support a very complex computations
since we're stateless if we focus on
consistency a nice use case would be
batch processing so for example the
MapReduce model by definition we don't
have any late results because we will
just if we see some new results we just
restart our computation from scratch and
it's also quite easy to scale especially
the mapping stage and a MapReduce
cluster but again we also have an issue
with complex computations since we have
to fit this MapReduce model with all the
computations we are doing and since
we're in the batch processing world of
course we have higher latencies lastly
if we focus on consistency index
passivity we could just say well let's
use a database since we have the acid
properties giving us consistency
guarantees and we are very expressive so
this is like the pinnacle of interaction
with the system we have even support for
declarative and recursive queries but
since we're talking about stream
processing this can't be a solution
since we are now using a database and
not stream processing anymore
so how do we obtain this trifecta and
maybe also why do we even care and to
motivate that a little bit more we're
introducing a small use case we're gonna
come back to time and again during this
presentation which should give you
calf:cow superpowers and it's not
entirely true that this is new it gives
you kind of database superpowers since
in a database you're the way you
interact with the database writing
queries is completely decoupled from the
way data is physically represented in
the system so for example using in a
relational database we're using tables
and rows and columns and tuples but this
is disconnected and decoupled from the
way you interact with the database
however if you use Kafka we complex
physical representation in your
downstream use case you first have to
decide in what format your data is in
your Kafka cluster using events using
partitions and if you then have some
downstream system that needs this data
in a very special format you're facing
trade-offs right you either you say well
okay we have some complex logic in our
consumers that join these data together
again or you have to just duplicate
logic on the event streaming site so
that you can feed it in the correct
format to your downstream consumers but
if you do doing that you're just
introducing redundancy so that is
inefficient and it increases your
maintenance load so what we propose is
that we again decouple streaming and
decouple the physical representation
from the business logic and we do this
by virtualizing partitions so first we
would which to virtualize we have to
somehow repartition our partitions maybe
even across topics and this also means
we have to think about joins now since
these virtual partitions need to
aggregate data and relate data to each
other from various partitions secondly
the virtual partitions themselves have
to have some notion about time since now
you have data from two partitions
flowing in
they are both time-stamped and somehow
you have to relate that these events
with each other in a way that makes
sense
lastly to walk the last mile to your
actual business logic and downstream
applications you kind of have to get
this data out there and a very modern
way to do this we think is using
reactivity so for example registering in
query on the client side and then your
data and the updates as soon as new data
arrives into the system
it's just fed to the user without him
needing to ask for it so one way to
think about a problem like that is the
so called data flow model in the data
flow model
what you do is upfront you describe the
structure of your computation using a
graph just like that where nodes in the
graph correspond to any kind of
operators that perform a function in
your computations or mapping filtering
joining all of that stuff and where the
edges indicate the pathways along which
data can flow between these operators so
to map this to this kafka example we'd
have the source operators reading in
parallel ideally from all of these
different Kafka partitions then we have
a bunch of computational operators
merging it together and finally we have
output operators called sinks that
connect to our clients and maintain
these virtualized representations that
muther just talked about the benefit of
kind of settling on a structure for your
computation upfront is incredibly easy
distribution because if you look at this
we can make copies of the dataflow
structure and simply shard the all of
our input data between identical copies
of our operators and so we're kind of
doing what Kafka is doing when it's
partitioning data physically and here we
can partition data onto our different
operators and if we then take these
operator copies and put them onto
different physical workers or threads or
machines in our cluster we achieve true
distribution of our computation okay now
if we look at a incredibly simple data
flow with just a single operator I've
called this operator sum and the idea is
that it receives time-stamped inputs so
each input count carries a logical time
indicating at which logical time this
input is supposed to have happened and
the operator is supposed to report the
cumulative sum of all of these inputs
and crucially it's supposed to report
the cumulative sum as of a consistent
logical time so incorporating all of the
data from a logical time stamp just like
a database would so if you play this
through
and we ingest the first top topple this
first topple carries the count of one
and is marked for the timestamp t0 we
simply report the sum of one for the
next couple it is marked for the
timestamp T 1 and so we report the
updated sum of 5 and now we are hit with
the late arrival because we ingest a
tuple that is marked for the times M T 0
for which we already reported in a
result so now we violated the basic
consistency guarantee because what we
reported for T 0 contradicts itself and
we did not reflect the entire state of
our database at times M T 0 so this is
the fundamental consistency issue that
we're talking about and at its heart
timely dataflow is an engine for
describing and executing these
distributed data flow computations that
prevent precisely this kind of
consistency issue through a mechanism
called progress tracking so if we now
revisit our example with progress
tracking the first thing you might
notice is that we've now in addition to
the data plane introduced a progress or
control plane and you can think about
these progress messages as similar to
watermarks and other streaming systems
such as flink and also our operator now
keeps track of what times at what times
it can still expect to see data so
currently we're at the start of our
system so operator can still see data
for every time starting with t0 and if
we now a process the first record at 1
and T 0 this also communicates to the
operator there still there still might
be more to come at t0 so we can't output
a correct result yet but have to store
it within our operator similarly if we
now ingest 481
we still provide this message well there
might be more to come at t0 so we still
can't output a correct result but now
when we ingest 3 at t0
we communicate to our operator
they're my we'll only data will only be
arriving starting from t2 onwards so now
for t0 we can create the correct
cumulative sum of 4 and 41 we can also
do that to arrive at 8 and this way we
as we have solved the central
consistency issue we faced before
returning to our Kafka example this very
basic operator is cool but we need more
complex operators for example drawing
operators so in this case we're using a
clickstream topic and a metadata topic
holding some kind of configuration that
we want to join through this clickstream
public for downstream Anila analysis and
an issue that arises here is that we're
seeing streams with very differing event
frequencies so our metadata topic only
has one conflict right now and this
never changes so if we now think about
what would happen with the way we did it
before we would ingest one to zero and
the metadata conflict at the progress
messages are T 1 and T 0 and we're
probably going to take the minimums or
join operator still works correctly but
then we are stuck at T 0 so our metadata
topic is indefinitely blocking our click
stream topic and our overall progress so
how do we solve this and this is very
timely really shines it introduces a
multi-dimensional time semantics so this
time we are tracking sources along
independent timelines and this way when
we now ingest something at T 1 so from
the click stream topic and join it with
the metadata topic we can just
independently look at our timestamps and
produce a correct result as of that
combination of times so since we are
advancing our progress to T 1 with our
click stream topic we can output a
correct result for T 0 and since our
metadata topic holds to 0 we can use the
combination and we don't violate our
consistency guarantee since this
combination is unique we will never see
a
nation of T 1 and T 0 in our system as a
result again lastly these progress
messages can also be used to communicate
progress downstream to further operators
and this is how also how progress
tracking propagates through your whole
data flow so again we can join and all
works out fine how does this actually
look in time e so this is a very real
timely data flow implemented in rust and
the first thing to notice is that we
always write timely data flows from the
perspective of a single worker this is
also a cool thing about the data flow
model at the stage where we write our
computation we don't have to care about
parallelization or distribution since we
can parallel eyes later on so we write
from the perspective of a single worker
then we create our data flow structure
itself which is very simple in this case
it's just an input operator then we
exchange some data across workers and
then we inspected and probit and this is
the first stage so we create the data
flow and after that follows the second
stage actually running the data flow by
feeding it data and this looks very
simple and it is very simple because we
have all these small decoupled operators
but as you can see we can compose this
into much larger and more complex data
flows while still in the end using these
very simple operators such as a map or a
concatenate if we now revisit our
example we can check what we have
achieved so far and we will actually see
that we've achieved the virtualization
part of things because we can do
repartition using the data flow model
and exchange operators and we can use
joins correctly as I showed you before
also in the actual virtual partitions
since we have rich time semantics we can
enforce time orders that make sense for
downstream consumers and this is what
time ii has given us so far so what's
missing from this is the last mile issue
so how does the data from our virtual
actually arrived at our consumers that
are downstream consumers and how do we
create this partition's ideally we would
like a higher level abstraction than
writing all of these data flows by hand
so we would like an interaction model
similar to a database again where we
maybe issue a query and have the data
flow be created for us automatically and
so if we kind of put this into the image
of the trifecta that we talked about
earlier what we saw now is how timely
allows us to navigate this trade-off
between the speed at which we produce
results and our correctness
so we achieve timely results without
viola while still providing strong
consistency guarantees and what's
missing is the extra civet e Corner and
we'd argue like if you think of your
favorite algorithm there's probably a
loop somewhere in there and it's the
same for query so if we think about the
complex kinds of queries that people
could have could ask of our system they
always involve recursion and you might
ask why is that and the reason for that
is that for complex use cases usually we
deal with data that is relational so
that looks more like a graph and less
like a simple list and if you want to
know anything interesting about a graph
most of the time you start with your
nodes in your edges and you start from
some interesting note that you know
about so in this case we have this very
small graph with just a few nodes and we
have the starting node C and from that
we perform an iterative exploration of
this graph to compute some properties so
for example here we go breadth-first we
explore all of the edges reachable from
C so in the first iteration of our
computation we discover the nodes a B D
E and we do something with them and then
we perform a second iteration of our
graph to reveal the final node F and up
arrive at the final result for
computation and this is why we mean that
there is this mapping between complex
queries and graph traversal and if we
think about how we would write a
dataflow like that in timely it would
look much like the following it actually
does look like the
the thing on the left with all kinds of
operators that seem very familiar by now
so maps and filters and joints the only
thing that's different is now we have
this thing called a turret and what the
intrud operator does it creates a data
flow like the one on the right so a data
flow that feeds data back into itself a
data flow with a cycle and if you think
about it for something simple like a
breadth-first search it makes a lot of
sense because one input of our
breadth-first search is the stream of
changes describing our graph so new
edges and edges that are removed and how
the graph evolves over time the output
of our breadth-first search is for
example the set of notes that are
reachable from our starting node and the
feedbag edge that loops back into the
data flow reports the transitive edges
that we discover as we iterate through
this graph now this looks a lot like the
problem that we had with the join
operator with two inputs because again
we can run into an issue where the
feedback edge for example is blocking
the input edge and vice-versa
and why is that so if we again think
about the changes to our graph in terms
of database transactions so we get
updates at T 0 T 1 T 2 etc we have to
perform all of the iterations for
transaction T 0 before we can start
processing subsequent transactions
because intuitively if we have multiple
transactions in flight the graph is
still evolving underneath your feed
right and so transaction one might see a
state of the graph that was never meant
to be visible to anyone because
transaction 0 is not finished yet so
we're violating the isolation principle
that we know from databases still this
is annoying again because now we have
we're blocking all of the transactions
that we would want to run especially in
the parallel setting we would know how
to interleave the computation we've
already seen that we can introduce
another dimension of timestamps to have
multiple transactions float through the
graph no problem because in this case
the second dimension that we would
introduce would be the iteration depth
so
the number of times we went around the
cycle and this would allow us to
interleave the computation but now we
have to think about how to ensure the
consistency guarantees that we violated
and if we think about what we did for
the join example earlier when we didn't
really enforce anything interesting
because the consistency guarantees were
very simple we always wanted that new
data on one input could see the most
recent version of any data on the other
input because we didn't care about the
temporal relations before and this if
you draw a kind of a visibility table of
what each transaction can see while it's
being processed you obtain something
like this which we draw for the
transaction that happens at clickstream
time t2 and metadata time t2 and this
transaction can see all of the previous
inputs on either of the transactions so
it can either of the inputs so it can
even see transaction 3 on the metadata
topic if that is already available and
so we have kind of we just hand
everything through as soon as we as soon
as we see it with iteration things get
more complex because as I explained
while one transaction is iteratively
exploring the graph we have to be
careful that subsequent transactions
cannot yet see this fluctuating state of
the graph so in this case we have to
restrict the visibility of each
transaction and to do that in this case
we use something called a product
partial order that gives us a table that
looks like this one so here as you can
see again for the second iteration of
transaction two we only can see up to
the second iteration of any previous
transactions so that we can make sure
that we only see committed data from all
of the previous from all of the previous
transactions and if we add so there is
many different orders that you can think
about for different use cases for
iteration it usually boils down to this
and this way we can make sure that while
we are interleaving all of these
transactions each one can only see a
state
the graph that is consistent that is
already committed to by all of the
transactions being processed
concurrently and still there's one issue
you might think that in a streaming
setting we could not possibly do more
complex graph computations yeah in that
setting like we do in a database if we
have to start from scratch with every
new input and that is true especially
for very large graphs so what we want is
our graph computations to be incremental
eyes so to only update in response to
changes instead of starting from scratch
on every new input and luckily there is
an extension of timely data flow called
differential data flow that provides us
with a set of functional relational
operators or join and without reductions
that allow us to compose iterative
incremental eyes computations or
computations that look like they are
written like a database query but they
actually execute only in response to
changes and update very efficiently and
any valid differential data flow is
actually also a valid timely data flow
because it just uses timely under the
hood for execution and the performance
of this approach works in practice and
we think also speaks for itself so here
for example we are computing the
connected component structure of social
network graphs or to find interrelated
groups of people for example and we have
all of these different systems using
over 100 cores to find this this
structure initially and even on a single
core differential is already
outperforming them for our at least
matching their performance for
evaluating the initial structure of the
graph still differential as we saw we
can simply scale the computation by
distributing our data flow onto multiple
workers so as you can see there for
example for the live journal graph
differential took 20 seconds to compute
the initial result with a single core
and as we go to two cores this roughly
cuts and
so it does scale as we add more threats
and machines and then the most salient
row probably is the one on the bottom
because that gives the time that it took
differential to update the computation
once it computed the initial result and
change happened to our graph
differential only took a few hundred
microseconds to update the strongly
connected component structure in
response to that whereas all the other
systems would have to start from scratch
and this is really where kind of the the
practicality of differential in a
streaming setting comes through okay so
we've seen how to write all of these
yeah recursive graphs the explorative
queries and with this set of operators
we have all the basic tools that we need
to implement a high-level relational
query language such as sequel or
graphical or data log in our case and we
actually built this project called 3df
short for declarative differential data
flows that implements an interactive
data log engine of a differential data
flow that gives you precisely these
semantics of queries that update in
response to new data and we'd argue that
in doing this and presenting this stack
we have kind of reached the trifecta of
stream processing because we described
how to model very expressive
computations without giving up either
the low latency that we want from a
modern stream processor or the
consistency guarantees that we would
want from a database finally if we now
one last time revisit our example we can
see that besides virtualization and
virtual partitions we can also check the
reactivity box since we can now use
something like 3df to issue queries
against these dreams that we've created
and get returned in a reactive manner
results as they flow into our system and
you might have guessed it this is not
only something that we thought about in
theory but of
course we actually implemented it so if
you're interested feel free to check out
croppers Iowa slash kplex that's what
it's called or of course come speak to
us after the talk in summary we have
introduced how many data flow to you
stream processing framework or yeah
stream processing processing a
computational model that use a state of
flows with multi-dimensional progress
tracking to ensure low latency data
flows while still remaining consistent
and we've also introduced to you
differential data flow which extends
timely data flow with iterative and
incremental eyes operators opening up
even more opportunities especially
concerning expressivity and lastly we
leverage differential data flow and
shout you 3df which is giving you
streaming relational queries so that you
can really interact with a streaming
system as if it was a database and this
is also the reason why we like to think
about timely as not only just some other
kind of stream processor but as a true
computational model which you can use to
write distributed systems while still
eating still staying sane and with that
we thank you for your attention and are
happy to take your questions thanks for
the talk can you give us a couple of
real-world examples of systems that are
using timely and sure so the from the
public visible point of view probably
there's there's very few right now but
so we've built commercial projects for
clients of us so for example distributed
graph QL engines with a get to match up
historic data query historic data that
is kind of unifying both like the badge
use case for obtaining datasets and the
online use case for kind of updating
them and so this kind of system
basically anything where you have a big
ETL pipeline and maybe the data is not
in the right
formats and you maybe have performance
issues with your spark cluster that is
where you use a timely system to do the
same job but do it faster
[Music]